falls ihr zug grüne und fdp das mit dem
legalen kiffen wäre eine art den vielen
jungen menschen danke zu sagen ihr euch
gewählt haben wo wir dabei sind können
wir nicht mal ein bisschen mehr für
studierende machen ja ich rede von der
vergessenen bevölkerungsgruppe der
korona krise dazu nun ein proseminar
live aus dem giovanni zarella lesesaal
der zdf bibliothek meine damen und
herren
studierende junge junge waren das drei
deprimierende semester hintereinander
oder so traurig so traurig wirklich ja
ich glaube wer 2020 angefangen mit
seinem studium der weiß überhaupt nicht
wie schön das frühjahr war studiert jura
nach bio geowissenschaftler bei in
koblenz was machst du denn hier laufen
und ich das fach hatte ich auch belegt
damals ja
so und selbst wenn es jetzt heißt die
universitäten kern zur normalität zurück
stimmt nicht wirklich stimmt leider
nicht in der praxis ist ein voller
hörsaal mit 3g regel und abständen gar
nicht machbar viele studiengänge finden
also auch in diesem wintersemester das
gerade angefangen hat hybrid statt
hybrid wissen sie kommt aus dem
griechischen und heißt soviel wie allein
im alten kinderzimmer auf dem laptop
glotzen ja mit allen ablenkungen wie so
ein laptop natürlich bietet sehr klar es
ist ja so es ist ja so entschuldigung es
gibt
wir haben übrigens ein mitarbeiter von
uns gezwungen dieses foto zu machen ja
dafür kommen wir in die hölle es gibt
erstsemester erstsemester die noch nie
einen anderen studenten getroffen haben
wie wird man wohl frage ich mich auf
diese zeit zurück blickt man wahrheit
kein student ich sehe mich auch nicht
als student die letzten zwei semester
ich sehe mich eher als ja quasi
arbeitsloser mit sehr großen
wissenschafts interessen
ja ja
nicht zu verwechseln mit arbeitslosen
mit großem interesse das sind gefeuerte
bild chefredakteure ja völlig völlig
andere geschichte über anderthalb jahre
haben studierende sich aus solidarität
mit den alten selber eingekerkert
sozialkontakte komplett heruntergefahren
zur belohnung weitgehend ignoriert von
der politik wobei winfried kretschmann
hat in einer legendären video konferenz
immerhin versucht heidelberger
studierende aufzumuntern mit den worten
vergleichen sie ihre situation mit der
anderer menschen dann werden sie sehen
dass es keinen grund dafür gibt
depressiv zu werden
mit anderen worten ja nun lach doch mal
ihr miesepeter hat er jetzt sogar als
trost buch herausgebracht es gibt keinen
grund depressiv zu werden die
fortsetzungen heißen eure wehleidigkeit
kotzt mich echt an
und natürlich buch student andere müssen
arbeiten geben
kretschmanns blöder spruch war leider
symptomatisch für die ignoranz der
politik insgesamt bei diesem thema die
vergessenen der korona krise viele
mussten wieder bei den eltern einziehen
andere haben ihre studentenjobs verloren
da hätte viel mehr hilfe kommen müssen
von den ländern aber auch von unserer
bundesbildungsministerin erinnern sie
sich noch an ja carlitscheck
oder wie ich sie nenne die andreas
scheuer der bildungspolitik
ja die müsste noch ideen haben was ist
ihr rezept für studieren in corona
zeiten möhreneintopf mid
hh
danke mir ist schlecht
karl checks corona soforthilfen haben
kaum geholfen weil man dafür nicht nur
nachweisen musste dass man fast kein
geld auf dem konto hat als studierender
sondern auch dass man wegen corona fast
kein geld auf dem konto hat wie soll man
das beweisen manche sind auch einfach
arm wegen der miete in den uni-städten
in diesem semester ist die wohnungsnot
da ja besonders schlimm sie ist so aber
auch
dazu hatte frau carlitscheck wir
erinnern uns ja schon einen ultimativen
tipp zitat man muss ja nicht in den
teuersten städten studiert ja völlig
richtig wenn du zum beispiel unbedingt
in münchen studieren willst aber in
chemnitz wo uns dann idee steigst du
morgens in den flicks bus nach bayern in
denen gibt es kostenloses wlan das heißt
auf dem hinweg besuchst du online deine
vorlesungen super dann in münchen
angekommen wendet der flicks fuß oder
auf der rückfahrt nach chemnitz kannst
du deine hausarbeit schreiben fertig ja
das geht alles wenn man will auch eine
schöne anregung an die ampel die sich
gerade bildet reformiert endlich das
olle bafög bafög wird in diesem jahr 50
aber jetzt kommt nur noch 11 prozent der
studierenden kriegen das laut
bundesverwaltungsgericht sind außerdem
die sätze zu niedrig in kaum einem
industrieland ist der zusammenhang
zwischen sozialer herkunft und
bildungschancen so groß wie bei uns in
deutschland das absolut beschämend gut
aber was jetzt die anderthalb jahre
corona zeit an der uni angeht da kann
man jetzt rückwirkend nichts mehr dran
machen das ist halt blöd gelaufen ach ja
jetzt bist du traurig weil bewohner dann
studentenleben versorgt kopf hoch das
kannst du alles nachholen später wenn
deine eigenen kinder aus dem haus sind
merkst du eben erst mit mitte 60 wieder
student der die damals nicht sein duft
ist und spielt zum beispiel mit einem
kommilitonen ganze nächte lang beer pong
scheiß doch auf die statistik vorlesung
morgen man ist nur einmal student
endlich erlebt ihr zusammen die schönste
zeit des lebens keiner ahnt wie alt du
bist also ab zuerst die party
wurde dann völlig zurecht verhaftet wird
[Musik]
dabei dabei ist es doch so wir brauchen
motivierte gut ausgebildete akademiker
zum beispiel in der forschung für die
nächste pandemie wo stehen wir in china
jetzigen das ist schwer zu sagen die
neuinfektionen sind auf einem
fünfmonatshoch wissen sie und zu viele
deutsche sind immer noch ungeimpft das
rp
das ärger ja neulich die impfquote um
fünf prozent nach oben korrigiert mit
dem schönen zusatz stimmt so
wahrscheinlich auch nicht ja jetzt
wirklich warum wissen wir nicht genau
wie viele hier geimpft sind dietmar
wischmeyer weiß es auch nicht tut aber
so
herrschaften ruhe bitte bis frage wie
viele bürger sind hier bereits geimpft
keiner weiß es rätselhaftes deutschland
im spätmittelalter der statistischen
demenz so wurde bisher unsere impfquote
ermittelt ist glaube ich selbst erklären
der arzt oder der spritzen durch im
impfzentrum meldet die daten falls der
zeit hat internet oder eine briefmarke
zur hand in den gesundheitsämtern sind
immer 27 gerade im wochenende oder es
ist weihnachten da wird dann per hand
digitalisiert beziehungsweise als fax
eingescannt und darüber die gute alte
kupfernetz ins rk ii gekabelt würde
nicht jedes bundesland und jeder
betriebsarzt mit einer eigenen software
hochadel werden es mehr daten die sache
sehe möglicherweise anders aus
möglicherweise sind in deutschland mehr
menschen geimpft als offiziell gemeldet
das ergab eine schätzung des robert koch
institutes die sich auf umfragen stützt
was man nicht weiß muss man eben raten
aber nicht einfach ins blaue rein dafür
gibt es ja das exakte instrument der
straßenumfrage man greift sich einen
statistischen durchschnitt germanen aus
der fußgängerzone und fragt ihn ob er
geimpft ist
wirklich
und das pony testen
kommt nicht infrage wer weiß vielleicht
hat sich ja das sprechende zäpfchen
heimlich impfen lassen leicht wird es
aber um von seinen kumpels nicht
verprügelt zu werden muss man bei der
neuen geschätzten impfquote mit
einrechnen und schon erscheint der spahn
vor der kamera wie ein frisch geimpftes
honigkuchenpferd die deutsche
impfkampagne ist noch erfolgreicher als
bisher gedacht das gibt uns zusätzliche
sicherheit für herbst und winter ich
vertraue mir auf die zusätzliche
sicherheit dass ihr in spanien winter zu
100 prozent nicht mehr
gesundheitsminister ist die idee für die
nächste pandemie und eine bessere
datenbasis klingt jetzt total crazy und
oldschool nennt sich und und weniger
rechnen ampullen morgens durchzählen
abends normal zellen von der ersten zahl
abziehen und schon hat man die anzahl
der geimpften zahl auf einen zettel
schreiben dann kommt lothar wieler
robert vorbei und sammelt die zettel 1
warum nicht auf altbewährtes
zurückgreifen stadt so zu tun als ob wir
schon im neuen jahrtausend angekommen
wären und nach einer schätzung des rkw
sage ich jetzt womöglich auf wiedersehen
hallo youtube unten könnt ihr den kanal
abonnieren er deutet nach unten in die
infobox neben mir gibt es weitere
interessante videos verlinkungen komma
vielen dank
[Musik]